- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools, and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights on who we
are, and how we got here. An exploration
made possible by the generosity of humans
like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Nina] We share with these beautiful
cousins of ours skin that serves a variety
of important functions, and we've heard a
lot about those functions already today:
protection, thermoregulation. Today, I'm
going to reprise a little bit of what's
been said already about the first two
functions, and then talk somewhat about
this enormous realm of human communication
that we engage in with skin.
Over time, and through evolution, if we
compare the relative importance of
protection and thermoregulation versus
communication, we can see that in human
evolution, communication has become one of
the major functions of skin especially
since the evolution of functionally naked
skin.
I want to first just reprise a little bit
information about protection, though,
because it's useful to think about what we
lost. Hair is enormously useful, and our
primate relatives and our mammalian
ancestors had hair that help to insulate
and protect against all manner of
environmental problems and abrasion,
ultraviolet radiation and water, and hair
helps to slow the ingress of pathogens to
the skin. But we lost hair, and although
there is some controversy about why we
lost it and exactly when, we know that we
now have functionally naked skin probably
by early Homo times, and almost certainly
for reasons having to do with the need to
keep cool during exercise by a high volume
of eccrine sweating. And what the
important conclusion of this is is that
for much of our...the key portions of our
evolution, hairless bodies are interfaced
with the environment.
A very different situation than in other
mammals.
The evolution of the stratum corneum, the
very top part of the epidermis is
something that has been dealt with a lot
in the dermatological literature. We know
that the epidermis, and particularly the
stratum corneum at the very surface of the
epidermis, here, resists abrasion,
restricts water loss, and prevents the
ingress of pathogens. But that great
change from the haired to the hairless
condition basically involved changes to
the stratum corneum.
So when we think about really what Ajit
Varki's point was at the very beginning of
this symposium, "Why is the skin
different." We see from referring to the
chimp genome project that in fact, the
skin is the most distinct organ. Human
skin has been...has many genes that have
been evolving independently, and very
different from those of chimpanzees much
more so than any organ or cell system. And
the most important genes in this regard
are those having to do with the stratum
corneum and the barrier functions of the
epidermis.
We could go on at length, my colleague,
Peter Elias has done distinguished work in
this area. We know that this stratum
corneum in humans is particularly
lipid-rich that we have interferon gamma
that helps to generate a potent antiviral
state in the stratum corneum and that the
skin microbiome plays an enormously
important and still quite unclear, but
emerging role.
The skin also has to protect against
another major assault which is that of the
sun and particularly, ultraviolet
radiation. We know from data provided from
NASA that the ultraviolet radiation load
that we get on the Earth's surface is
strongest around the equator shown in the
bright pink and red tones here in the map.
Much, much lower as we get close to the
poles, especially in these large land
masses in the northern hemisphere. How
have humans coped with these high levels
of UV in our ancestral areas, and much
lower levels in areas of habitation later
in aspects of our evolution?
In early Homo, the loss of body hair is
associated with the development of
permanent, dark pigmentation. So instead
of having dark hair covering lightly
pigmented skin, we evolve permanently,
darkly pigmented skin. And that is largely
to do with the production of high amounts
of the tremendously interesting pigment
called eumelanin; a fascinating polymer
that has myriad important properties. The
most important for our purposes being the
ability to scatter and absorb ultraviolet
radiation and prevent damage to underlying
tissues.
Ultraviolet radiation causes a lot of
damage to the skin that can lead to skin
cancer, especially in individuals who are
genetically susceptible. But skin cancer
rarely causes mortality.
So I, as someone who is interested in
figuring out why skin pigmentation evolved
as it did, and specifically why dark
pigmentation evolved, got very interested
in the effect of ultraviolet radiation on
something that would really count for
reproductive success in evolution. And I
started looking a lot at folate
metabolism. Without going into a lot
detail, suffice it to say that we need
folate, one of the key B vitamins, in
order to fuel DNA synthesis which is
particularly important in certain parts of
our development in life especially in
early embryogenesis. When we know that
folate is critical for the formation of
the embryonic neural tube which is the
precursor of the modern, or the adult,
nervous system. So, if you have an
environmental agent like ultraviolet
radiation that can actually break down
folate and affect other aspects of folate
metabolism in a pregnant mother, then you
can affect reproductive success, and this
is why we've highlighted that mechanism.
So.here I say the primary, not the only,
but the primary selective force for the
evolution of permanent dark pigmentation
is protection against ultraviolet-induced
changes in folate availability and DNA
synthesis in early embryogenesis and in
sperm production. But humans did not
remain in the ancestral environment of
Africa. Much of human evolution, including
much of Homo Sapien's evolution, has
occurred in Africa. Tremendous amounts of
diversification, but humans have moved
around a lot.
And here we can see in the history of
modern humans. We have people
moving...small populations moving out of
Africa into areas of very different
ultraviolet radiation including very low
areas or very low UV areas later in our
evolutionary history. Why is that
important? Because ultraviolet radiation,
mostly a malign influence that we think
about in evolution, is a creative
influence, and is extremely important in
all vertebrates in the production of
Vitamin D in the skin. Without
ultraviolet-B radiation we cannot make
Vitamin D in the skin. And what we have
shown in our research and this has been
supported by many collateral lines of
evidence is that the primary selective
force for the evolution of lightly pink
bennet [SP] or more correctly, depigmented
skin is promotion of ultraviolet
radiation-induced Vitamin D production in
the skin under conditions of low and
seasonal ultraviolet radiation.
And so here in modern humans, we have this
beautiful and delightful contrast between
skin on the left that maximizes photo
protection against ultraviolet radiation,
and skin on the right that maximizes
photosynthesis of Vitamin D under
conditions of low UV.
Skin pigmentation is a superb evolutionary
compromise. Something that we should talk
about in our classes of evolution and
human biology; a superb compromise that is
an excellent illustration of the action of
natural selection on the human body.
Themoregulation, I'm only going to say
that as we evolved through time, we became
far more active. This beautiful example of
an early member of the genus Homo was not
a tentative biped. This was a striding,
running, active individual that built up a
lot of body heat under hot environmental
conditions.
Here was the natural selective substrate,
as it were, for the loss of most
functional body hair. Evaporation of sweat
is impeded by hair, and so we reasoned
that most body...most functional body hair
was actually lost because of the
importance of facilitating the evaporation
of sweat from the surface of the body. And
so, functional hairlessness, then, can
best be thought about as facilitating
active body cooling, whole body cooling,
through eccrine sweating during lengthy
periods of sustained exercise.
Communication has always been an important
function of skin, whether we're talking
about a distant mammalian ancestor or a
primate relative. Primates touch one
another. Communication through touch
especially beginning with infant-mother
communication is central. This continues,
and is elaborated in the hairless human
infant and in hairless bodies contacting
one another. And we know that this type of
touch communication is absolutely
essential for mother-infant bonding in our
primate relatives and in ourselves.
When we lost most of our body hair, we
lost an important method of displaying our
emotions. This chimpanzee on the left is
exhibiting a display, a very visible
display, of anger and aggression toward
the individual on the right.
And he is able to manifest this
magnificent raising of hackles. What do we
do without hair? We have no hackles. We
might...our little feeble hairs might go
up. What do we do instead? We don't know
for certain, but what we do know is that
modern humans have much more finely
differentiated, and highly active facial
muscles than do even chimpanzees, and we
have the evolution of enhanced facial
expressivity in humans that is probably
related to that loss of expressivity in
the raising of the hackles.
As soon as humans evolved naked skin or
probably very soon, thereafter, people
realized that they could decorate their
skin. We don't know when they happened
upon this, but we have some enticing
evidence that comes from Blombos Cave in
South Africa from about 70,000 years ago
that would indicate that by that time,
people were beginning to use ocher for
decorations and for decorating the inside
of rock shelters. This is exciting because
I would venture that probably long before
this, humans had been using ocher and
similar pigments to rub on themselves, to
mark themselves. We can't prove this, but
it seems highly likely. Humans are lavish
decorators of themselves. We may not have
colorful fur, but we more than compensate
for this by having myriad ways of
decorating ourselves with body paint, with
cosmetics.
In most cultures, both sexes are involved
and many parts of the body are involved in
decoration. There is no culture that we
know in the world that does not adorn its
skin in some way. Modern humans have
developed not only body paints but also
cosmetics. Now, mostly associated with
women, but certainly centuries ago, not. A
lavish form of communication that is
incredibly important that individuals can
manipulate and change from one day or one
season to another.
We also start making permanent marks on
our body. We know from the preserved
remains of the so-called Tyrolean iceman,
dating from around 5,000 years ago, that
we have evidence of tattooing of the skin.
These are thought to be therapeutic
tattoos that were on the skin not
necessarily decorative. Many of them are
crosses or simple lines, parallel lines.
But the fact that they are present that
early in the archaeological record in
neolithic humans is significant. And
humans around the world tattoo themselves,
and sometimes lavishly.
This woman from Burma has beautiful facial
tattoos that signify her marriageable
status. And that identify her to a
particular clan group. But what do we say
just through our color? And the rest of
this lecture I want to devote to the
messages, the communication that actually
comes from our color.
During most of human history, humans moved
around slowly. They came into contact with
one another gradually. There were no big
surprises. And it's not surprising that
through much of history, not just
prehistory but much of history, we have no
indication that humans treated one another
differently on the basis of color. It only
is relatively recent, in the last few
hundred years that color becomes something
that has social significance, and that has
some kind of set of stereotypes and even
stigmas attached to it.
We really see the emergence of a modern
color-consciousness beginning in the 18th
century when innate skin color comes to
communicate both racial identity or race
belonging, and social status. One of the
most interesting figures in this history
is the philosopher Immanuel Kant. Immanuel
Kant was a very careful reader of
Linnaeus, the great taxonomist. Linnaeus
made very simple descriptions of humans
according to skin color and geography.
Later, he associated skin color and
geography with some characteristics of
behavior and culture.
Kant was an avid reader of Linnaeus, and
Kant, although he's known far more for his
thoughts on rationality and human
thinking, had tremendous curiosity about
human diversity, human origins, and the
origins of human capacity for
civilization.
And so, he thought a lot about Linnaeus
and what Linnaeus said, and Kant, not a
naturalist, but Immanuel Kant the
philosopher, was the first to actually
enunciate the presence of four races. And
the key thing about Kant's races where
that in his mind, they were immutable.
They couldn't change ever. And this was
just not a list, it was a hierarchy. And
critical here is the primacy of the white
race which is something that we see
emerging again in different guises for
many centuries, for many decades after
this.
Kant's tremendous influence was
complemented by the importance of
maintaining a strict social hierarchy in
order to keep the trans-Atlantic slave
trade going. By the early 1800s, there was
tremendous pressure to end slavery, to end
the slave trade. But it was very, very
financially appealing and important for
the hierarchy of races and especially the
primacy of the white race over the
so-called black race to be enunciated so
that slavery could be maintained. And we
see this complementarity between a
philosophical and a religious or
pseudo-religious underpinning for race
hierarchies and slavery along with the
mercantile and capitalist underpinnings. A
very pernicious system that led to the
social differentiation of color.
Something that hadn't existed at least in
as strong a form and violent a form
before. And so we see race definitions
that are associated with color that lead
seemingly inexorably to the development of
racial stereotypes especially when they're
propagated by individuals like Kant, like
Thomas Jefferson who were highly, socially
influential through their writings leading
to the development of what I've called
color memes that are adopted and
transmitted from family to family,
generation to generation leading to a
durable psychosocial template for racism.
So skin, coming from this delightful and
beautiful evolutionary background, skin
color actually reflects our evolutionary
history, but in this most recent part of
human written history comes to represent
something entirely different. But I am not
a pessimistic person, and the beautiful
thing about humans as primates is that we
are tremendously imitative and suggestible
and we can change. We adopted in Western
civilization broadly, certain attitudes
toward color and we can change those
attitudes. We're not trapped by the color
memes that we have created. And this
aspect of communication through skin can
in fact change. I want to celebrate the
beauty of human skin and invite you to
think more about the exquisite path that
skin has taken through the last seven or
so million years of the human lineage.
The evolution of hairlessness, functional
nakedness, sweating, the development of
these marvelous appendages, and the
beautiful feast of microbes and other
creatures that live on the surface of our
skin. And then, the superb things that we
do with this beautiful, naked canvass that
has been produced by evolution. Let's
celebrate those and continue an active
program of research. Thank you very much.
♪ [music] ♪